what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this
and hit that notification bell so you
never miss an update
this is another video in my our tutorial
series
and now if you've seen some of the older
videos we've worked through a number of
libraries from the tidy verse
we've seen deply r gg plot 2
tidy r lubridate string r
and basically we've got down a number of
functionalities like manipulating your
data and getting it into a nice format
so that you can visualize it
and then also some different
functionalities for just dealing with
different types of data
well today we're going to take another
step back from that and we're going to
look at things like
functions and then how you can apply
those functions
over multiple different elements or
vectors
now just a few things before we get
started number one
please take half a second of your time
to smash the like button
because that really does help my content
reach a larger audience
i will also have a link to my patreon
account in the description of this video
so if you guys would be willing to
support me over that way
that would be massively appreciated and
then also
this script as always is going to be
available on my github repo
which is also in the description of this
video now without further ado let's get
started
so what i want to start off with here is
sort of the motivation for writing
functions in the first place
and i'm going to show you this by first
pulling in the empty cars data sets
that's available from the tidy verse
and i'm going to create a data frame
called in this case data set
so i'm going to showcase why functions
are important
by sort of showing you a counter example
so
check out what i'm doing in this next
chunk of code here
so i'm creating these three variables z
disp zhp and zd zdrat
by basically creating z scores out of
the different variables that i have here
but there's a few problems here first of
all
if you just look at this code it's a
little bit
difficult to read now granted what i'm
doing here is not exactly
massively complex but when you look at
this
your eyes are on all these variables
which are showing up
you've got data set dollar sign disp
minus the mean
of data set dollar sign disp all divided
by the standard deviation of data set
dollar sign disp it's just the same
thing going
on over and over again just repeating
this variable
and it's a little bit ugly on the eyes
and not only that
but if you look at my third line of code
here
i don't know if you caught it but
there's actually a typo in it
so i was copying and pasting this line
down
and then i missed the data set dollar
sign
hp at the end which really should be a
dollar sign d
rat that could happen to you too you can
be
repeating your code over and over like
this and then you end up making typos
and other mistakes like that and
it just causes you problems so
a good rule of thumb this is what i like
to call the hadley wickham rule
but if you're repeating your code more
than twice
it makes sense to write a function
instead
so what i'm going to do here is as an
alternative is
i'm going to start by i'm going to start
by calling this
chunk of code first of all but i'm going
to start by
refreshing my data set here because i
made changes to it
then i'm just going to create this
function called standardize
i'm going to just create some new
variable y
that's equal to given some input x
x minus the mean of x divided by the
standard deviation of x
return that new y variable that's all
there is to it
and now i'm going to just call this
standardized function here
three times and just look at this it's
so much
cleaner and easier to read than all this
junk up here was
because over here when your emphasis
was on these variables which just kept
getting repeated over and over
over here the emphasis for your eyes
when you see this
is on this function that's being done so
it's just much much better i know this
is a very simple example
but i hope it really does impress upon
you just how
useful writing functions is now the next
thing that i'm going to show you
are loops so the two key types of loops
in
r are the for loop and the while loop
we're going to start with a for loop and
i actually want to preface this by
saying
i use loops all the time but whenever
possible
i recommend not using them now we're
gonna see why towards the end
but first of all with loops they're not
the fastest way
of applying a function over multiple
elements
and frankly because of just the
beautiful vectorized nature of
r you just don't need to deal with loops
all that frequently so again you're
going to see that
towards the end just alternatives that
we have to use in loops
but like i said i do them sometimes
you'll probably do them sometimes and
you need to know them
so i'm going to show you a super simple
example
i started by calling this data set and
isolating the variables that i need so
i've got a number of
quantitative variables here and i just
want to do something super simple
all that i want to do is create a vector
and then every element of that vector
stores
the mean of one of these variables so
okay that's pretty straightforward right
so let's start by initializing this
vector we're going to call it call means
and the length of this vector is going
to be equal to the number of columns of
this data set
so again one element for each of these
variables
so here's our syntax for a for loop it's
going to iterate
through one up to the number of columns
in the data set
and you can call it whatever you want
your iterator here i'm just going to
call it i
but then coal means for every index
i is going to be equal to the mean
of the ith column of this data set
okay so we're going to run this
and look at that we've got a
we've got a vector that has all of our
column means
now one pretty nice thing that you can
do with for loops is you can nest them
and i'm going to show you an example uh
with a matrix here
so i'm going to create just a straight
up empty matrix i mean technically it's
not
empty because i'm just creating the
number zero
uh in a five by five matrix but
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
replace these zeros
with the row and the column index
for each of the elements of the matrix
so
what i'm going to do here is i'm going
to iterate
through all the rows of the matrix using
an iterator
called i then inside of that i'm going
to iterate through all the columns of
the matrix
i'm going to call the uh the iterator
here j
and then for the eighth row and j
column element i'm just going to paste
the text of the row iterator
comma the column iterator so
let's just take a look at that and see
that it works we're gonna do that and in
the first row
uh first column we've got one comma one
for the let's say third row second
column we've got
three comma two pretty straightforward
right so now that hopefully you get the
idea behind for loops
let's take a look at while loops now i
created an example here which was
heavily influenced from this example
that i found from uh this website guru
i think this is a really practical sort
of example
when you might want to use a while loop
in a more practical sense
but let's take a look at this example
here and we're actually going to
start from the variables i'm declaring
then we're going to look inside this
loop
so i'm going to initialize this variable
called stock
let's say that's just a stock price
we're going to start with
days equal 1 and then i'm going to set
the random seed here for reproducibility
purposes to be five five five and now
inside of this while loop here i want to
iterate
uh over the stock variable here i want
to add to the stock variable
uh some random noise based on a uniform
uh random variable going from a minimum
of negative five to twenty
so just basically adding a random noise
here that is expected to be positive
and then this days variable i'm going to
increase it
so that's all going to occur while the
stock variable
is less than 350. so i want to basically
find out how many
let's say days or runs of this loop
rather that it takes for the stock price
to hit 350.
so we're gonna do that and um
yeah it basically takes uh six days here
and the stock price at the end was 353.2
so that's pretty cool stuff right now
while loops i don't personally use them
a whole lot
when i do use loops i use for loops
significantly more but
like you just saw here there are
certainly some instances in which you're
uh going to want to know about them now
there are some other types of control
statements out there
uh inside of r we've got next we've got
repeat and we've got break now these
things are
fairly straightforward and again these
are not things that i happen to use a
whole lot
but they are out there and they'll help
you control your loops
so i'm not going to show you examples of
them here but
you should have them on your radar just
to know that they exist
and then if you need to incorporate them
into a loop sometime
again i think they're pretty
straightforward to figure out
one control statement that i am going to
show you here though is the if else
statement
because i use this one all the time so
the if else function has three uh
arguments to it
there's a logical condition that you're
going to check if it's true or not
if it's true it's going to evaluate to
the second argument
and if it's false it's going to evaluate
to the third argument
so what i want to do here is i just want
to create
uh this variable hp above average
which is going to be equal to true if
the z-score
zhp is greater than or equal to zero and
false otherwise so i'm just going to run
this
bam i created this hp above average
variable pretty quickly
we see in these instances in which the
chp is less than zero
it evaluates to false and when it's
greater than zero it evaluates to true
so again pretty easy to figure out
and it's a function that i use all the
time
all right so that's about it for loops
and control statements
now the last thing that i want to show
you here is the apply family of
functions
and i must say this is absolutely one of
my favorite types of functionalities in
r
i highly recommend getting used to these
because when you can use these to
replace a for loop
pretty much always you should because
they're significantly faster
and they're just a lot more
syntactically uh concise than writing
loops
and so the idea here is we're going to
apply
a function over something else so we're
basically going to repeat
a function multiple times and we're
going to see some examples of this
so we're going to start with this base
apply
function now what i'll say about this is
i've got the help documentation open in
the in the corner here you might not be
able to see it because my face is in the
way
what i'll say is it is a little bit hard
to read at first
i totally understand that so i'm going
to try to break it down for you here
for the apply function there are three
key arguments here
number one is your data frame then
number two
is your margin and that's either going
to be the rows or columns
if you want the rows you put one here
if you want the columns you put two then
the third argument
is a function that you want to apply
over that margin
so that is simple enough right
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to do apply
data set to mean so i want to apply
the mean function over the columns of
this data set
i do that and i basically produce just
like i did before
uh the means of all the columns of the
data frame but notice this is
one single line of code that was faster
and just frankly a lot
easier uh to read and to write
than that for loop that i showed you
before there's plenty of other functions
in this family and i'm going to show you
two of them
here that's l apply or s supply
uh you may hear me calling them laplay
or saply just because you can pronounce
them but
just know that's what i'm referring to
now there are some others in this family
that i'm not going to show you
like v apply t apply and m apply
but again the two most common that i use
are l apply
and s apply and it's easiest to see
how these work by seeing an example so
i'm going to start by creating this list
called x i basically ripped this kind of
from the help documentation for uh for
these functions
but it's gonna be a list where the
element
a is a vector going from one to five
we've got uh this element
beta which is an exponent going from
negative
three to three and then we have this
logic
vector which is true false false true
okay so what this l apply function is
going to do
is it's going to apply the mean function
to each element of this list let's run
that and let's look at it
okay so of element a we got a mean of 3
of this element beta we got a mean of
4.535
and of logic here it sort of converted
these to numbers on the back end and it
returned a mean of 0.5
so i'm returning singular values here
but
i'll apply does is not uh constrained to
that
you can return whole vectors here so
rather than apply the mean function to
each element of x
i'm going to apply the quantile function
i'm going to pass another argument to l
apply here with
the probabilities or the probes that's
an argument to the quantile function
which is passed as an additional
argument to l apply here
let's see what we get look at that we
got the 25
50 and 75 quantiles for uh for each of
the elements of x
so this is an absolutely awesome
function
and the possibilities for it are
completely endless
you will see here that l apply returned
us a list
now what's nice about the supply uh
function is that after it creates this
list here
it's pretty smart and where applicable
it's going to convert your output into
either a vector or into a matrix
so let's see an example here i'm going
to run s supply instead of l apply
for that example with the mean and now
instead of a list
i have a named a numerical vector
similarly for that quantile example i'm
going to use supply
and i have a named matrix here instead
of just a list
so super super helpful function
again i use these constantly so i'm
going to wrap this up by sort of
bringing all this full circle
so remember right at the beginning of
this tutorial when i created that
standardized function and then i used it
three times
one time for different variables of the
data set that i was working with that i
wanted to create z scores based off of
so let's take making our code concise
to the next level so let's just say
i want to use the s apply function
over the data set specifically just over
the vectors
disp h p and d rat
i want to apply the standardize function
so
i turned three lines of code that i was
using earlier
into just one line of code here so
i'm gonna that's gonna return me a
matrix i'm gonna convert that into a
data frame and then i'm going to give it
uh i'm going to give the columns names
output that that data frame and then
look at that
i did a lot there and i took only four
lines of code to do it
now if i just want to append this to to
my data set
obviously that's pretty easy to do so
we've seen the motivation for creating
functions here
and then how to use functions in an
iterative fashion
by using either loops or the apply
family of functions
now i want to point out these are not
the only way that we can skin this cat
there is the per r package as well as
the fur
package which provide functionalities
for us to do these types of things
but there's a lot going on behind those
packages
so they're totally the subject for a
different tutorial
hopefully now you know how to use loops
and you're very familiar with the apply
family of functions because believe me
once you become an
established art programmer that family
of functions is really going to be your
friend
so thanks for watching this video leave
me a comment down below
smash the like button and then i'll see
you all in the not so distant future
until then richard on data